ونحييكم من جديد في انتكاسه كبيره للاتفاق
النووي الايراني الجديد كما يبدوها في ظل
المفاوضات بين موسكو وطهران بشان انشطه
الاسلحه النوويه الايرانيه نقلت قناه
الامريكيه ان ايران ابرمت صفقات سريه مع
روسيا لضمان اليورانيوم التي حصلت عليه
موسكو من طهران ابانا الاتفاق النووي كما
افادت مصادر استخبارات اجنبيه ان رئيس
روسي بوتين وافق على اعاده اليورانيوم
المخصبه الذي حصل عليه من ايرانه اذا
انهار الاتفاق النووي المحتمل وقال
مسؤولون المخابرات ان بوتين او ان بوتين
الذي قام برحله خاصه الى ايران لمتابعه
صفقات التسلح بين البلدين وافقه على طلب
الايراني على ما يبدو بسبب اهتمامه بتعويض
الايرانيين ومساعدتهم في المقابل انتهز
الايرانيون الفرصه وطلبوا بضمان النووي
يمكن ايران من استعاده مخزونها من
اليورانيوم بسرعه الى مستويات التخصيب
التي حافظت عليها قبل استئناف الاتفاقيه
وقال مسؤول الاستخبارات ان محاوله التحايل
على واشنطن والقوه الغربيه الاخرى ستؤثر
على الهدف الكامل للاتفاق النووي الايراني
مشرين الى ان هذا من شانه تقويض المصالح
الامريكيه بشكل كبير
وسيمنح روسيا سيطره فعليه على الاتفاق
النووي في الحاضر والمستقبل وفق قولهم
مسؤول الاجنبي
لن نعلق على التقارير المخابرات السريه
المزعومه ولكن على اي حال خطه العمل
الشامله المشتركه لم تكن على جدول الاعمال
منذ الشهور
مصادر استخباراتيه اجنبيه في اطار الاتفاق
بين البلدين تعهدت روسيا باعاده كل
اليورينيوم المخصب الى ايران في اسرع وقت
ممكن اذا انسحبت الولايات المتحده لاي سبب
من الاسباب منظمه متحدون ضد ايران النوويه
الصفقات الجانبيه المبلغ عنها بين ايران
وروسيا بشان الملف النووي تظهر فقط مخاطر
الاعتماد على موسكو كمشارك او ضامن في
ترتيب شبيه بخطه العمل الشامله المشتركه
لقد تغير السياق الجيو السياسي بشكل اساسي
مع الهجوم على اوكرانيا لايران نفوذ على
روسيا عام 2023 لم يكن لديها ذلك عام 2015
نناقش هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفنا من موسكو
المحلل العسكري اهلا بك من باريس ساندرين
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي اهلا بكم ضيوفي
اسمحولي ان ابدا باريس معك سيد
اندريه حضرتك ما الذي فهمته من هذه الصفقه
اليوم هناك اخبار تفيد بتسليم روسيا
لليورانيوم المخصب الايراني الذي كان مجمد
من بعد الاتفاق النووي طيب ولكن
ما وراء هذه الصفقه ما الاسباب هل روسيا
تتحرش تستفز الغرب او روسيا مضطره لفعل
ذلك مقابل مسيرات
مساء الخير طبعا هذه الاخبار هي حتى الان
مجرد تقارير تقارير استخباراتيه نقلتها
بعد وسائل الاعلام بالعلويات المتحده
الامريكيه الولايات المتحده الامريكيه او
حتى الاتحاد الاوروبي لم يعلقوا بعد رسميا
لا بالنفي ولا بالتاكيد وكذلك الامر
بالنسبه لموسكو وايران اذا نحن اليوم امام
بدرجه الاولى هو محاولات ربما حرب اعلاميه
تسريب اخبار بهدف معين محدد لعده اسباب
طبعا اليوم هناك الطرفان الروسي والايراني
كل واحد منهما بحاجه للاخر ولكن كل طرف
لاهداف محدده روسيه بحاجه للدعم الايراني
ليس فقط من من اجل مسيرات الحصول على
مسيرات وهناك اتفاق لبناء يعني ايران
تساعد روسيه لبناء مصنع من اجل انتاج هذه
الطائرات المسيره ولكن هناك حاجه ايضا
متبادله من اجل التبادل المالي من اجل
التبادل المصري في والتبادل ايضا
الشحنات
الطاقه البترول والغاز بما ان العقوبات
تطاول البلدين وهناك اتفاق بينهما مع
الصين بعض الدول الاخرى مثل الهند وما الى
ذلك اما بالنسبه للروسيه اليوم تسريب هذا
الخبر قد يقيم مفيدا لروسيا اولا لكي
توحلي ايران بان على استعداد لمساعداته
والوقوف الى جانبها في الملف النووي
الايراني في مواجهه الغرب لكي تحصل
بالمقابل على مزيد من المساعدات الايرانيه
في مجال المسيرات والامور الاخرى التي
تحدثنا عنها وايضا من اجل الضغط على
الاوروبيين الذين يحاولون اليوم او يسعون
لان اجل تزويد اوكرانيا باسلحه متطوره
اسلحه جديده سمعنا بان الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ستبدا قريبا بتدريب طيارين
اوكران على طائرات اف 16 وبالنسبه لايران
الامر يفيدها حوض لو كان مجرد اشاعه تصيب
اخبار لانها المرحله التفاوض مع الوكاله
الدوليه من بعد ما ظهرت اخبار عن زياده
تخصيب اليونان الى ما فوق 80% للقول انها
اذا كانت الوكاله الدوليه لن تستجيب لبعض
مطالب ايران وبالتالي الولايات المتحده
طبعا فانا لدى ايران ستكون القدره فعلا
للتلوح حلول الاخرى وليها عفوا
ولكن هناك لاعب اساسي في كل هذه الامور هو
اسرائيل اسرائيل لم نسمع بعد موقف اسرائيل
جديد عن هذا الموضوع لان اسرائيل هي
الاولى المعنيه بهذا الامر والتي تشعر بان
هناك خطر وقد يكون خطا
وقالت بانه لن تسمح بذلك صحيح ولكن قلت
حضرتك بانه هذه اقرب اقرب صحيح ولكن قلت
حضرتك بانه هذه الاخبار هي اقرب منها الى
بروباغاندا اعلاميه لمحاوله الضغط ما رايك
سيد سيرجي
هل هي بروباجن دا اعلاميه لان روسيا لن
تلعب مثل هكذا لعبه مع الغرب
موضوع المطروح هو بمثابه روايه
مبنيه على تقارير
يقال انها استخباراتيه ماخوذه من مراجع
مجهوله ونشرها الصحف غربيه
فنحن نعلم ان في سابك وسائل الاعلام
الغربيه كانت تستعمل اكثر من مره في نشر
المعلومات الكاذبه الاساس لها او
المعلومات التي تم نشرها بالضغط من قبل
الاوسات المعنيه في في العرب المعلومه ان
هناك تعاون ميتين وطويل الامد بين روسيا
والجمهوريه الاسلاميه
والتشبه
المجالات كفه بما فيها التعاون في مجال
النووي
المعلومه هناك محطه نوويه في بوشير
تم بناؤها بالمساعده الفنيه
والتكنولوجيه الروسيه ولكن هناك شرط واحد
التعاون النووي بين روسيا وايران
يتم تنفيذه في اتجاه
السلمي فقط فقط
لا يمكن باي شكل من الاشكال ان تقدم على
هكذا خطوه وان تسلم اليورانيوم المخصب
لايران لاي حسابات كانت ابدا ابدا اطلاقا
لان هناك معاهده عدم انتشار الاسد النوويه
وكل دول النادي النووي دون استثناء تلتزم
بالبنود المثبته في هذه المعاهده فلا يمكن
ان تقدم روسيا او غير روسيا سلاحنا
ونراجع من مخصب الى درجه
التي تسبح باستخدامه في تصنيع النوويه الى
اي طرف اخر
فهذا مثل ما كنت في البدايه روايه لا اساس
لها لها من نصيحه
حتى
تثبت صحه هذه الاخبار من عدمها ولكن في
العموم العلاقه المتينه الحاليه على الاقل
التي تجمع ايران بروسيا قد تفتح كذلك
المجال الاستفهامات
ومخاطر يقول الغرب بانه هذا التقارب لن
يفيدهم في شيء حضرتك هل هناك مخاطر فعليه
من هذا التقارب في هذه المرحله الحساسه
بالتحديد وما هي
طبعا بس بالنسبه لهذا الموضوع يعني يقول
الضيف من موسكو بان الغرب اعتاد على تسريب
مثل هذه المعلومات
ولما لا يمكن ان احتمال اخر ان التسريب
جاء من قبل اما الاستخبارات عن مصادر من
روسيا او من ايران من اجل احداث هذه
البلبله على كل حال اليوم هناك مخاطر طبعا
المخاطر اليوم على عده جبهات بالنسبه
لاوروبا هناك مخاطر على الجبل الاوروبيه
مع اوكرانيا مع روسيا
الخوفيه من الحصول على اسلحه اضافيه
ساعود قليل يبدو بان هناك خلل بسيط على
مستوى الصوت ولكن
يقول بانه هذه المعلومات المسربه
يمكن ان تكون يعني نابعه عن روسيا او عن
ايران وليس
يعني فرضا عن الغرب عن الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه اوروبا ما رايك
انا لا اشارك هذه وجهه النظر لان المعلوم
ان لا تهران ولا موسكو اكدت رسميا لحد
الان وصوله المسيرات الايرانيه الى روسيا
واستخدامها في القطان في اوكرانيا
طالما هذا الموضوع
وموضوع اخر مرتبط بذلك
الاتفاقيه التي يقال انه تم التوقيع عليها
بشان
تجهيز سلاح الجو الايراني بمقاتلات روسيه
ايضا لحد الان ليس هناك اي شيء
يثبت هذا الموضوع رسميا اذا ماذا تستبعد
لماذا تستبعد ان تكون او ان روسيا هي من
فجرت او من سربت مثل هكذا معلومات ضيفي
منذ قليل يقول بانه من مصلحتها كذلك ان
تجث نبض الغرب فيما يخص هذا الموضوع ان
تحضرهم ان تقول لهم هناك مسلك اخر يمكن ان
اسلكه اذا ما طورتم الموضوع وصلحتم اكثر
لماذا تستبعد ان تكون روسيا وراء ذلك لان
هذا الاسلوب ليس بطبيعه السياسه الروسيه
نعم كانت هناك تصريحات من قبل الذي
حدد
بالخطوط الحمر وهدد الهرب
فرض العقوبات بما فيه استخدام السلاح
والضربات الصاروخيه على المعدات الغربيه
في حاله دخولها للراضي الاوكرانيه ولكن
هذا الكلام ظل كلاما اذا كما نعلم
التحديدات بهذا الشان الخطير وبالفعل
الملف النووي هذا موضوع جدي للغايه وهناك
دوله وهناك دوله اسرائيل وهي تراقب كل
تطورات مرتبطه
بالملف النووي الاراضي بكل الانتباه فلا
يمكن
استخدام هذه الورقه في هذه اللعبه الموضوع
[موسيقى]
صحيح احنا وضحت هذه النقطه فقط كانت تعليق
على سيد اندريه عطله جديد بعد خطينا لهذا
هذه المشكله البسيطه من عندكم ولكن كنت
تحدثني عن مخاطر مخاطر هذا التقارب
بالنسبه للغرب خلينا نفصل هذه المخاطر
ونقرا تداعياتها بعناوين بارزه لو سمحت
نعم كما ذكر الضيف المخاطر اليوم هي
اللجوء الى استخدام السلاح النووي هو امر
من يعني من صعوبه جدا حتى يمكن القول من
الرابع المستحيلات هو سلاح ردع رادع يعني
يقيم توازن الرام من دون اللجوء اليه
بالنسبه للغرب حصول ايران على السلاح
النووي حتى لو كان رسميا الخطاب الرسمي
والمرشد لا يقول بان هذا هو ضد العقيده
وضد الدين الاسلامي ككل ودود عقيده النظام
ولكن مجرد ابقاء هذا الغموض حول قدره
ايران على انتاج السلاح وقبل ايام قالت
الاداره الامريكيه ان يلزم ايران حاول 12
يوم فقط يجعل من التوتر اول التوتر في
المنطقه وهذا التوتر قد لا يمكن احتوائه
وعندها ستجرى اوروبا والغرب عموما وحتى
روسيا امام جبهاتنا عده من التوتر
والتصعيد ممكن ان اسرائيل تستخدم هذا
الامر كحجه حتى من دون التاكد وجود عمليا
نقل هذا اليورانيوم من اجل القيام بضربه
استباقيه اليوم الدفاع الامريكي
وكان ضيف
ي
انها تقدم على هكذا خطوه ولكن سيد
لو سمحت هل يمكن ان تكون في مصلحه ايران
باعاده احياء اتفاق 2015 او اي اتفاق كان
يخص الملف النووي
انا اعتقد انه ايران من خلال ما زارته من
هذه السنه الماضيه بهذه المحادثات منذ
توقفها حتى حين اجراء الجولات الاتفاق هي
لا تريد العوده الى الاتفاق لم يعد
يناسبها بالاساس هذا الاتفاق كان نوى من
الغطاء بالنسبه لايران هو مرحله من الوقت
تستطيع خلاله ان تقوم بمجهودها الحرب
وترقيه نفوذها بالاخص من خلال السلاح
الباليسطي ومن خلال القوى المؤيده لها في
المنطقه كان في لبنان ولا في العراق ولا
في اليمن او في غير ذلك من الدول حتى تثبت
امر واقع لانها كانت بذلك حصلت على نوع من
الهدنه مع الغرب مع الولايات المتحده
تحديدا من اجل بناء الاتفاق سيصل الى
نهايته في عام 2025 بعد اقل من سنتين يعني
حوالي 20 شهر اذا ما الغايه منه اذا لم
تحصل ايران على اضافات الاضافات التي
تريدها لا تتضمن في هذا الاتفاق وشعوبه
الرئيس
هناك معضله في ايجاد حل الوسط صحيح ولكن
انتهى اعذرني على المقاطعه انها التوكيل
الخاص بهذا
السياسي وشكر كذلك لحظرتك ضيفه من موسكو
سرقه العسكري شكرا لكما